Jake hey thanks for coming and hanging
with thank you you know how excited I am
to be you are excited and I see you got
the memo love the black leather and
black shirt yes and a little bit of
chest hair yes we've got it we're good
we're good
congratulations on all your success I
mean Heartland that's my DJ and of
course Shadowhunters which is massive
there is such a fandom for that series
how are you feeling about things
wrapping up on that series let's look
the fandom has been there before we even
were yeah because the books and because
everything so they've got their world
going on you know and and they've sort
of absorb doesn't embraced us so much
and celebrated us and for me I don't
have any like difficulty like moving on
and like but moving forwards because I
look ahead I look forward and I know
that everything we've built isn't going
anywhere and you know the show itself
the TV show is it's just a small
fraction of the actual realm and the
whole world that we've all created so
I'm just taking everybody with me and
I'm going forward so I'm excited there's
so many people who are curious of how
it's all gonna wrap up and I know you
can't give any spoilers but if you could
sum up the finale Open Series in three
words for me what would you say I would
say epic obviously
battle and unite unite all right and
that one has many layers - yeah looking
forward is so important and when one
door closes another opens that's an old
saying right yeah and that series that
make probably give you a chance to do
this new cbc series the 410 which is
fantastic congratulations and the series
took place why why did you want to be a
part of the series in the first place my
friend super new rats who created it is
one of my really really good friends and
anything she would do I would want to be
part of it be honest she told me about
it like she she had me in mind for this
part for more than two years didn't tell
me yeah and during that period I was I
was asking myself you know I've done so
many like big stuff and very independent
stuff and there's different feelings
that come with both like different
satisfaction that comes with both and
I've been wanting to feel satisfied and
fulfilled creatively we tend to think
that like the bigger something is the
more fulfilled and complete you will
feel and that is not true at all I was
in that place in my mind where I was
just like okay I work for people I love
for people I respect who respect me back
yeah I want to create art I want to feel
good I want to give a good message I
want to tell a real story she told me I
could wait out here like a dog oh gee
I'm so sorry I gotta go
everyone's mcgucket me since across the
fourth time for anyone who doesn't know
the premise of this series I need you to
break it down for me right okay so okay
there's a lot there Assyrian so it
follows Surrey okay and she's from a
South Asian family and then she receives
a phone call so that's what happens she
gets a phone call we know I give too
much yeah it's pretty it's like content
that we haven't really seen before it's
about you know a family of drivers like
truck drivers and sort of what goes on
in that scene and smuggling some stuff
yeah I mean can we talk about this yeah
there's smuggle there's drugs you know
and it's actually like a thriller you
know when you watch it and it is I
honestly sat in my office and I just
went episode there's three episodes and
I like I told you before we started this
I wish there was
many more because I feel like the story
was just so well written it's well
directed its character driven it's
fantastic I love JJ I love JJ yeah I
loved it they just like part of me for
sure I've always wanted to play JJ in
any form and and it's funny because
we've had a conversation like with soup
and they're like who is he he Ziya he or
is he not a he you know is he it's C
trans in transition is not is it just
gays just like fabulous like what is it
so in the end we just came up with like
JJ's this is just J there's just no
explanation and it just doesn't need to
be a label which is kind of like my
whole message I love just not having to
give a label to anybody that we are just
ourselves and you know obviously in
society we have to categorize everything
just so that the other can feel
comfortable yeah it's just interesting
and you know and some people like to
have a label just to assert who they are
which is nice too but it's about the
society that that's why we do that and I
like to just be who we are we're just
humor that's it and that's my message
exactly we're human and the rest is just
like decoration
how does it feel because you're a bit of
an advocate for the LGBTQ community does
that carry a certain weight for you no I
mean it's who I am and if I would if I
was silent about it I would I would feel
like I'm lying to my mission in life all
you have to do is be yourself like
yourself goes way beyond any label okay
any label at all and and it's actually
limitless and infinite so just tune into
who you are like that's the only face
as' that's what we need to do it'll come
out the way it is and you'll have to
explain nothing to nobody and people
will meet you they'll like you and then
if they have a you know some sort of
judgement about LGBT anything yeah when
they have met you and couldn't place a
label on you because you were just you
then they'll change their mind because
they'll be like oh that person was gay
or that wasn't was trans I had no idea I
had no idea you love Sascha yeah you
could tell love fish so what do you love
about fashion four years ago
no this is no no four years ago I was
like I want to be a fashion sort of like
ambassador yeah you know I have a lot of
friends that are in fashion mm-hmm and
they inspire me so much and their
lifestyle is so exciting to me and I
love people who make art yeah this was
made by a friend of mine and I wanna
wear it
I want to collaborate and wear people's
art and sort of showcase it and if I can
be that for people than grace you know
something else you're doing that super
cool is music congratulations thank you
tell me all about the music and I know
you're kind of branding yourself a
little differently when you look and
this is you know this is this is also my
way to say like to honor Shadowhunters
and and meliorn my character has this
hair color in his hair and so you know
cutting it represents like moving
forward but then the color is also like
you know honoring the past in a way and
I'm creating an EP called love letter to
a fandom for the fans yeah you know
we're gonna start there and because
music is really what I want to do like
if I could just do that for the rest of
my life I'll be so happy yeah like
collaborate with artists create videos
create like all kinds of projects so
yeah so I have about like six tracks
right now my first single is gonna come
out in June exciting very exciting
everything's sort of coming together and
you know I'm open I don't really know
how or how it's going to spread or
anything like that but it's very much
based on my relationship with the fans
right now and it's gonna launch from
there and then and then we'll see so
what's a dream you still have what is
something you want to achieve my music
is like my dream right now I wanted to
go to a place that's that's very big and
different from what I've been doing and
and I can feel it and I was very
inspired to launch this whole project
and now it's interesting because it's
like in a different phase where I have
to sort of package it and sell it so the
inspiration is sort of in and out at
this point but but I can still feel the
vision of it and but this interesting
thing is that the vision that I've had
for my music has been the same vision
hasn't I know it's been the same as my
acting so it's all been one big sort of
vortex of feeling that
been after and this is just a new piece
that will kind of bring it to a new
place another dream of mine is to be a
guest judge which you know give me a few
years and they'll be there well
congratulations on everything
thanks for coming it has got to be
honestly like this elects like a dream
oh my god no truly well come back
anytime
[Music]
you